by being a racing driver you are under
risk all the time I used those lines in
those guidelines to move as a man as a
professional I like to do well I like to
be the best I am as committed as ever to
my passion
everyone is responsible for the race
having beans but I'm only 32 and it's no
it's a Brazilian race driver who won
three Formula One World Championship he
was killed in an accident while you're
leading the 1994 San Marino Grand Prix
is considered by many as the greatest
racecar driver of all time
he's our Constanta and here are his top
ten for this day
you should know that by being a racing
driver you are on the risks all the time
by being Eurasian driver means you are
racing with other people and if you no
longer go for the gap that exists
you no longer a racing driver because we
are competing we are competing to win
and the main motivation to all of us is
to compete for a victory is not to come
third four three four six he kampala to
do for long presses greetings
Jakob disrespect adobo chicken SSI he
kisses poor instituto succeed o team
winter moon Picabo tranquilly dodgy
[Music]
y-yes a Soria music silica gentei kaijo
insta Mejia guarda sabemos chicas chin
solando we procure on do in in Azaz
Mikado's na e eco como
ash hey gravis power sub de sisse Gouda
younger and problem-solving team it's a
fantastic site typical Haley also
metazine student - Aaron it must be hard
to feel in every opening remark is
taking in cuando free and I have had all
my life
very very strong in good education and
from that education have got again clear
and strong principles in way of behaving
and that's where I'm guide for I come I
use those lines and those guidelines to
move as a man as a professional and and
I don't regret anything I just feel I'm
doing things for the right reason some
understand from don't in the end you'll
never get everybody to understand to
agree and to accept but most of them I'm
sure a de Meyer of all what I am doing
as as a professional and as a man and as
many driver do we are exposing our lives
that are consistent and the reason for
it is only one is to succeed is to win
is to get the flu when you cross the
finish line in first place I am very
competitive I think any racing driver
that gets to Formula One has in its
personality a lot of competitiveness
I particularly believe to be extremely
competitive in anything I do but it
depends where you are and what you're
doing what is your state of mind if I am
on holiday offseason
it's a different way of living totally
then when you do interviews when you're
testing during the season racing
competing in the signal you have to
allow yourself different men to approach
a different way of looking day and night
and only that way I find possible to get
the necessary Librium - then give
everything I have when it really matters
but in normal things I'm competitive I
like to complete and I like to to do
well I like to be diverse
pommie responsabilidad Toby's my agua
que todos mis my squad Nina na de la
cosa que es porque essentially says
Nastya so Zuma Maggie - ow un Colleen
Greg EW motiva my friend ago say Roku de
tránsito walk when space appraise
y-intercept so de todos esos Adagio
infancia question so Co Co Co V de
Levante instead o Jurgen la casa de pie
na sediment character dramatist missing
here para here so how much Abed like
Neal Conan Coulter miserable day Aten it
has been quite incredible season for you
you are the youngest ever three times
world champion three times in four years
I have to ask you on behalf of your
despairing rivals
is your motivation still as high as ever
I think
I I am I said young I am healthy I am as
committed as ever to my passion to our
passion and to my profession and the
main thing is to find ways time after
time to stimulate myself in my own or
dying my own funny ways to dedicate a
lot of my time a lot of my thinking and
keep up with the commitment that is
quite high to continue to be successful
if we were to run into rain conditions
of this kind again is that a better
method even for us to look into how the
way should be stopped earlier or more
positively we shouldn't start but whose
decision is that in it I think it's very
hard for the officials to make such a
decision because there is a lot of
question television all over the world
and and it's difficult we understand but
I think it's in a way is our own fault
we should have started the drivers if we
just get out of the cars stick together
and make a decision ourselves then the
race wouldn't start in first place it's
always very difficult to get everyone
together I experienced it myself two
years ago today again because also we
have a lot of responsibility to the
teams and disposals that give us so much
and there are moments that we have to
also try to give them something but he's
very difficult to find the equilibrium
the balance on making the right
decisions at every single time but as I
said I think it was a mistake to all of
us to have start not only from the
officials it was also a drivers mistake
was a team's mistake we all should have
had courage as a group everyone that is
here to get together and go against it
and not risk not start the race so it's
not officials only I all
so take responsibility think earth
drivers and also the team everyone is
responsible for the ways having being
stuck i express the feeling some time
ago a couple months ago that time I
wouldn't be prepared to continue driving
next year unless I felt I could compete
competitive and that meant not that I
had to leave McLaren or anything it just
meant if you feel you you have some
light at the end of the tunnel in which
you can work and make up and be back
around in a competitive way and if that
situation did not turn up for me then I
wouldn't drive without really wishing to
stop because I mean I'm only 32 and it's
no sense for me to stop I mean the peak
of my career is to with quite a few
years ahead I have achieved so much
credibility in so much experience that
is is not the time to stop but on the
other hand absolutely nonsense to just
be a number out there giving the fact
that whether you fight him for first or
second or a fee for a six
she just exposing yourself to a lot of
danger continuously a lot of stress
and the lifestyle that not always is
he's attractive for me and therefore
considering everything the material
benefits I got up until now and the ones
I could get in the future the personal
satisfaction the achievements that you
can get the only real motivation for me
to continue was to to be in a position
where I could complete improve learn
more and and be there you know be there
fighting at least for it anything else
just I could not justify to myself
so the villas are the century without
much more nice to be supposed to be free
image assault so awesome
in what decision the changes with
objections before muhidinova tarah51 he
was a fox TV costume Aguada
in gt2k was before Israel okay the song
she was a pain reliever
we hope she saw Microsoft in centimeter
sorts of material so it's a profitable
item or ecommerce angles change
emotional which are more efficient
well you can look at this video from
grandpa Raziel this is the colliculus or
uniformly simply discard range is
showing go Erica
Oh
[Music]
and pulled out believe it was then
really faced with a very easy race win
[Music]
and the gearbox chanted he was faced
with several obstacle only having a
severe para symposia pelota Ricardo
momento para trabajar Moses Tomas Ella
quiere para linkage iam eyes portulaca
mice educate empower total represents a
Frenchman because you here in control
Delta de Lima force especially
[Music]
laughter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
isn't going oh yeah you smile for you
will show momentum mais la
[Music]
David OTT Garces prayer we achieve
aspiring school the rhombus disposal
yeah boy Arabs living with lots of money
caracals president of minority health of
PSAs Rhema cabaco visa and a disability
thank you so much for watching we make
this video because the best money access
to so the famous entrepreneur that you
want us to profile next week in the
comments below I'll see what we can do
we will let you know which one of his
happens and you like this most please
leave a comment below we will join you
in a succession thank you guys for
watching seems to believe and confusing